um I'm venkat guruswami I'm a senior
scientist here at the Simons Institute
and it's my great pleasure to invite you
all to the boot camp of the meta
complexity program uh this spring and as
you know the Simons Institute is a
leading Center worldwide for
collaborative research in theoretical
computer science it was established in
2012 more than 10 years ago
um
with a generous Grant from the Simon's
foundation and it continues to operate
with generous support from the Simon's
foundation and various partners
and each semester
um The Institute brings together the
world's leading researchers in some
topics as well as the next generation of
outstanding young researchers so
typically we run two programs each
semester Each of which brings about 70
visitors long-term visitors Junior and
senior plus visitors for each Workshop
and this is actually the 10th year of
programs at the Simon's Institute we
started in 2013
um for with actual programming and I
think we and the whole Community can
feel proud of the achievements of the
programs which have really pushed the
frontiers of the field in so many
directions solving long-standing old
open problems making progress on them as
well as opening up new directions of
inquiry and connections to other
Sciences engineering Humanities and so
on
and this semester we have a program on
meta complexity as well as an extended
reunion on satisfiability Theory
practice and Beyond and I believe uh
that program The Reunion also has a lot
of connections with this program so that
should be exciting the second half of
the semester
and this week we kick off the activities
for The Meta complexity program with the
boot camp and for those who may not have
attended one of these boot camp is
intended to acquaint program
participants with the key themes of the
program
and it will consist in this case of four
days of tutorial Talks by Leading
experts on the topics of the program and
our sincere thanks to the organizers of
the program and also this boot camp who
are Tony pitasi if you're here wave your
hands but I'm sure everyone knows you
all Rahul santanam Valentin cabinets and
Rafael pass
they will see at least three of you here
so thanks uh let's give them a round of
applause
[Applause]
and before I hand it over to Rahul to
introduce the workshop and give that
first talk as well uh a few logistics
for the coming week first of all all
talks are live streamed as well as
recorded for posting on the Simon's
website and where they enjoy a life and
impact long after the boot camp finds
down and especially for the boot camp
these talks have really served as a
valuable resource for students and
researchers worldwide to learn the state
of art about some very important topic
so you know I think they're a great
resource even more so for the boot camp
and some other sort of logistics on the
week itself food is provided before the
first talk and during the breaks just
outside for lunch you're on your own but
there are many options within walking
distance and we have also arranged the
weather to turn back to its normal world
for this week so there should be no
problem walking to get lunch and we do
request sincerely that you leave all
food and drinks outside uh before
entering the auditorium so that keeps
the auditorium um nice and clean as it
is now and if you do need to store
something during the day
um
um so there are lockers on the other
side where you can lock your valuables
and
um
and our videographer Ahmed far is around
to help with all speakers and set up so
if you have any issues setting up um it
should not be a problem and and I
believe this is not hybrid right is
there a zoom thing going on
okay so there should be a zoom link but
I don't know who's whether the session
chair is monitoring but you can
and uh and finally before I hand it over
a special round of thanks to our events
team kelani Penland
um she's there waving find her if you
need anything and she's also helped by a
hashley uh Ashley Hassan and Elizabeth
un who should also be around this week
for managing all the logistics to
arrange uh this and it always goes very
smoothly and sincere thanks to them and
with that said uh without further Ado
I'll hand it over to Rahul to introduce
the program
yeah it's great to see so many of you
here I am Rahul santanam I'm one of the
organizers of this program and of this
Workshop
um so thanks first for the Simons
Institute for all their um support for
making this possible and for the
organizational help as well
um so just to give you a sort of um like
plan for for this week um so the boot
camp is really
um meant to get you all up to speed able
to talk to each other you might be from
different backgrounds
um computational complexity proof
complexity crypto and to um just sort of
like um get you up to speed on the basic
concepts of this of the area of matter
complexity
um so there's going to be four days of
talks and the first two days are going
to be mostly about complexity Theory and
learning theory
um the the third day is going to be
about crypto and the fourth base when we
are proof complexity
um so just in terms of the schedule
there's
um sort of like potentially a couple of
changes so one of our speakers for
tomorrow is unwell so we're not quite
sure he's going to be able to make it
here in person
um so he's either going to be giving his
talk online live or he's going to be
recording it and it'll be available for
you to watch later and we'll let you
know about that later today depending on
on how he's feeling
um and on the on the third day um so um
the original order had um uh tall market
and then Rafael pass but now it's
switched and Rafael speaking first and
taller speaking the afternoon
um so it's just sort of uh minor changes
in the program
um
so um with that done let me sort of get
get right into it so um what I'm going
to be doing this first talk is just
going to give you a very basic
introduction and overview so um um just
what what meta complexity is about what
the basic Notions are kind of like what
Calgary is and so forth
um and
um feel free to interrupt me at any
point and kind of like ask questions
it's it's meant to be interactive
um it's and this is really set the stage
for the speakers later so um for
Valentine later today and for um the
speakers in the following days
um and so you might see something for
the first time here and let's see it
again on on a later occasion and that's
how it should be because we'd like to um
to re-emphasize things the more
important thing so that so that they're
clearer
um so so let me get started so first of
all um like what is meta complexity so
it might be a relatively new term for
for for many of you
um and it's an area that's seen a lot of
research recently
um but what does it refer to
um so essentially medical complexity
refers to the study of computational
problems that are themselves about
complexity
um and sort of the prime example um the
one we'll be starting with in terms of
the discussion is the minimum circuit
size problem but um there's also more
classical problems such as the problem
of computing chronograph complexity
um and there are various others which
we'll we'll survey in this talk
and um I think of Medical Practice
myself in in two ways one is sort of
like a narrower way where medical
capacity is as a topic there are all
these conversational problems or
complexity and you want to understand
which complexity classes do these
various problems lie in what complexity
low bounds can we show for them what
reductions exist between them and so on
what kinds of relationships exist
between these problems so that's sort of
like a narrow interpretation of meta
complexity but um eventually I mean the
motivation comes from elsewhere and
we're we'll be more interested in the
broader implementation interpretation
which is medical complexity as a two
really we are interested in meta
complexity because it's relevant to
fundamental questions in many other
areas
um not just in competition complexity
but also learning theory cryptography
and proof complexity
um and so um we're interested in using
the ideas the concepts the techniques
the tools and attacking these
fundamental questions
um and through this boot camp hopefully
you'll get a much better idea of of how
that um how that would be done but I'll
give you some sort of a sense of it here
in the stock using several examples
okay so um this first one hour I'm going
to be focusing mostly on
client is the topic introducing you to
various complexity measures the
computational problems that are
associated with them
um what is known about their complexity
and and so on
um and towards the end I'll say a little
bit about medical complexity as a tool
but that's going to be reserved mostly
for the next talk where um I'll kind of
illustrate it through 10 major open
problems in in these areas all of which
America capacity is relevant to just to
give you a sense of which kinds of
problems um we might be interested in in
addressing through this uh through this
program
okay um so um sort of like the key
problem
um that we're interested in is a minimum
circuit size problem ncsp
um so um this problem is sort of like a
fundamental problem which has been
studied for a while and especially in
the in the past um couple of decades so
the problem here is that you're given
the truth table of a Boolean function f
so function from n is little n Bits to
one bit
um so the truth table has size two to
the little n and a parameter s and um
you want to know does f have Boolean
circuits of size at most days
okay so um that's mcsp so you're given
well the truths table which is this long
string of exponential length of the
input length of this function f and this
parameter s which
um the sensible values for S anywhere
between 1 and 2 to the N
um so and and you won't know what the f
has circuits or size at most as and then
there's sort of um a variant of it so
there are many many variants of these
medical complexity problems and and as
the stock goes on we'll go we'll see
more and more of them but but for now
we'll just see these two variants so the
memory circuit size problem and the
parameterized variant where you also
have some function s which is sort of
given in advance
um let's assume that s is some
polynomial term computable function that
sort of maps the the length of this
truth table to some number and the
question then is given this truth table
you don't have this number as a
parameter anymore but you ask whether f
is Boolean success of size S as a
function of the truth table length
okay
um so um one way to think of mcsp is as
an example of a black box problem so um
and what sense is it a black box problem
they're given some sort of explicit
reputational Boolean function that is
its truths table and you want to know
something about programs or circuits
Computing it you won't know if it has
some sort of succinct description using
circuits
um and well you might wonder you're
given the complete truth table so in
what sense is that black box is Black
Box in the sense that you're kind of
given the input output behavior of the
function you're given for each input
whether it's um the input value is to a
one or a zero so you're given the input
output behavior and you won't know
something about
um what the um the computation
complexity of this function is
um does it have small circuit complexity
or not
um so yeah it's sort of like very
roughly it's a black box problem
um and by interpreting a string as a
truth table of a Boolean function we can
think of circuit size as a complexity
measure of a string right so
um for any string um so it might not be
of length two to some power to some
integer part but let's assume that you
sort of like um truncated so that the
length is a power of two just consider
the first so the if the strings of
length between two to the n and two to
the N plus one you just take the first
two to the end bits and you can think of
that as a truth table for Boolean
function and then you can ask about the
circuit size of the Boolean function so
that gives you some sort of complexity
measure of a string telling you how
simple or hard that string is
um and in a way what mcsp is doing is
answering questions about complexities
of input strings um it's a conditional
problem that's naturally associated with
this measure
um and what we'll be doing is we'll be
defining various other complexity
measures defining computational problems
that are associated with them and asking
questions about these computational
problems complexity questions about
these computational problems okay any
questions before yeah so should there be
SF login
um yeah so you can kind of like think of
it either way for now I'll say s of n
because that's the convention we're
dropping through the stock but it makes
more sense to say as of login because
say it's exponential size then you want
it to be asked to be due to the Epson
example yeah
foreign
corresponds to polynomial sites
okay so so just very briefly about why
mcsp is interesting for the point of
view of complexity I mean we'll have
more to say about that later but just
for now a sort of a basic observation
um which is that this the long-standing
problem of asking whether exponential
time has um small Boolean circuits so we
don't know
um whether exponential time requires
super polynomial size Boolean circuits
um and that question is essentially
equivalent to explicit constructions of
no instances of mcsp so uh it's equal to
efficiently constructing no instances of
mcsp with the parameter s of log n of
size n given input 1 to the N so um
um yeah why is that so um so in One
Direction so we want to show that these
two things are equivalent that these
circular bounds for exponential time is
equivalent to these sort of efficient
constructions here and efficient
construction I mean a construction that
runs that time polynomial in in capital
N
um so suppose you had an efficient
Construction
of no instance of mcsp namely given one
to the end you're constructing some
truth table of size capital N
um that um is a no instance of mcspf of
log n
um well that gives you a way of
generating the truth table of a hard
Boolean function because that's what a
no instance is for mcsp like if you
generate a true table efficiently you're
generating the true of a hard Boolean
function and if you can generate true
table hard Boolean function in
exponential time then that defines an
exponential time language right you can
kind of like look up the value of the
supposed to give an input X you can you
can generate the truth table in
exponential time and then look up the
value for x in the truths table so you
can solve that function in exponential
time so um in One Direction the
sufficient construction gives you
exponential low bounce of exponential
time and in the other direction if
there's a language in exponential time
that doesn't have small Boolean circuits
then we can just um take this language
and generate a truth table and turn to
the order end just by sort of running
the expansion time machine through it
and all 2 to the N inputs so that takes
time 2 to the N times 2 to the order n
which is exponential uh and all and it
gives you a truth table of lengths two
to the little n and that's generated in
time to do the order n and this The
Strokes table so thinking of two little
and as capital N is
um of size capital n and it's generated
in time poly of N and this truth table
is going to be a no instance of ncsp or
passive login right so
um it's a fairly straightforward sort of
connection between these two problems
and I'll just point this out because
it kind of like gives you some
indication of what makes mcsp a tricky
problem to analyze if you think of like
um most problems that you encountered
they um generating yes or no instance of
them can be is fairly easy like for
satisfiability if you want to generate
yes and since there are no instance of
satisfiability that's trivial you just
generate a a formula which is just x and
x and so on or you can generate a
formula it's not unsatified like X is
not X so that's easy to do but
um it's it's not that common perhaps to
come across computational problems where
explicit constructions are difficult
these things only for infinitely many
lines
um yeah so if
it's for um construction works for all
input lens then you get an almost
everywhere low bound
um and I think you can prove like an
infinitely often version of that as well
okay so what can we say about the
complexity of mcsp
um so um well first of all mcsp is an NP
and that's not too hard to see though I
mean
um if you're not used to working with
this problem it might seem kind of like
order first
um so why is mcsp and NP well you're
given the truth table why which is a
size capital N for Boolean function app
and you're given a parameter s how do
you solve this problem in NP you guess
some circuit C for f of size S note that
the only sensible values for S are at
most capital N because if the function
has small circuits if the functional
circuits the best exercise at most n
um so you can assume that timer to S is
at most n so we guess the circuit of
that size and you check that Y is a
truth table for the function computed by
C and you can just do that by by kind of
running C on every possible input
um in this truth table so there's
capital N many inputs and you just run C
on on every such input and see what
value it outputs um and each such run
takes time poly of s and so the total
amount of time for running C on all of
these inputs is is poly of s times n
um and we just verify that c of Z is
consistent with Y where the Z bit and Y
so Z index is some bit and Y you you
check that that bit is consistent with C
of Z is the same as C of Z and if you do
that for every kind of bit of truth
table then you know that um this is the
correct circuit right so the point is
that this whole check time is polynomial
in the size of the truth table I mean of
course it involves kind of like running
over every input in this truth table but
that's okay because you're given the
entire truth table as input so this is
the polynomial time check and hence this
is an NP problem
um so yeah one of the main open
questions about mcsp is is it in p and
we don't believe that it is
um like the naive algorithm for mcsp is
to run over all possible circuits and
check if they work right so
um if you want to know if there's a
circular size at most desks you kind of
try every possible circular size s and
check if that computes y correctly
that's going to take exponential time
um and there's some evidence that mcsp
is not LP if one-way functions exist we
know that mcsp is not in fee um uh and
that builds on serial function
generators which should kind of shown to
Exist by code right gold awesome
McCallie based on standard crypto
assumptions and then Ross from rudition
and cabinets and PSI are useless to show
that connection between one-way
functions and mcsp not in p
um and well the other question then is
if if we believe NC speed is not in P
what can we say about the harness when
CSP is an mcsp NP complete
um and um there's been kind of like
varying sort of beliefs about this for a
very long time I mean the more it seemed
the more obstacles showing NP
completeness and any evidence that mcsp
was empty hard but um but slowly over
the past few years has been sort of a
lot of progress on this question and
Rahul alango will be talking about this
tomorrow and and very recently hirahara
showed that a version called partial
mcsp which seems very similar to mcsp
instead of being given the truth table
of a Boolean function you're given a
truth table with some don't know symbols
some some positions you have a don't
care symbol it could be either a zero or
a one and you want to know there's a
circuit that's consistent with this
whether on all the zeros and ones the
circuit evaluates correctly and the
don't knows you don't care what the
circuit does so that's a version of the
problem which is very similar looking to
the to the problem and this version is
np-complete and so are some other other
kind of quite natural versions so
there's there's this result there's
several other results which I'll kind of
talk about later so there does seem
evidence now that mcsp is likely
anti-compete but we're still not quite
there in terms of having a proof
yeah uh so given this result and what
you said earlier about explicit
instructions does this mean we now have
efficient ways of generating hard
partial truth tables and is that
something that we already knew before
this yeah well uh so actually this these
kind of Productions are randomized so
yeah so um yeah randomly we can't
generate them yeah
um okay so let me just say something
very brief is talking I'm not going to
spend much time on this because I it's
this is really about like getting up to
scratch on these complexity measures and
problems relate to them but it's
interesting that I mean though mcsp
might not be a problem that you've kind
of like heard about that much it's been
starting for a very long time since the
1950s actually by by theorists in the
Soviet Union under different names long
before there's even any work in
complexity in North America or even
before NP ussp was was kind of like a
stated as normal problem and there's
this great survey by tractor and
Broadway talks about this early uh kind
of like work on mcsp and related
problems
um and in fact Leonard Levin um as
report very calendar publishing his
results in np-completeness
um he had all these results of NP
completeness but he really wanted to
show that graphas motion factoring and
mcsp were NP hard and so he kind of
delayed publishing his results
thankfully not for too long and he did
published enough time to get credit for
it um in 1973. um but this is one of the
problems that he's stuck on he wanted to
show that mcsp was NP hard
and the recent recent interest in the
problem earlier follows and kind of work
of cabinets inside who defined the
problem and kind of like showed various
kind of interesting things about it and
that itself builds and work of Ross
Province
um uh and their paper National proofs
which is really about meta complexity in
disguise
and there's a few other sort of
important papers of this area which sort
of trigger a lot of work but we'll get
to them as we go along
um
so as I've said before I mean mcsp is
intuitively a black box problem right
given like the input output behavior of
a function by screws table we are given
explicit representation and we want to
know this Boolean function has small
circuits
um and um what about white box problems
so mcsp sort of like a canonical example
of a black box problem and the chemical
examples of white box problems are
Boolean satisfabity and its variance so
these are sort of like inverse problems
given the representation of a Boolean
function as a formula circuit and you
asked information about the function
computed by these uh by the formula
circuit so for example whether the
function has a one in a truth table as
Boolean satisfiability the question of
how many ones it has is counting set and
so on and so forth so
um like the white box complexity
essentially corresponds to to saying
something about the function given as
representation while with black box
promise you want to know something about
the representation given um the truth
table or given Black Box access
so um it's kind of interesting to
compare these two kinds of problems to
each other
um
and um of course we know a lot about
satisfiability we know the satisfibility
is MP complete um and this has been used
to show many other problems NP complete
um in practice we use
um sat and sat solvers to solve empty
heart problems by reducing them to sat
and then running a SAT solver on them so
um the Epica cleaners of sat has various
practical implications as well it allows
us to solve problems very um kind of
efficiently in in practice
um then of course there's lots of
theoretical sort of implications of that
completeness of sat and work their
Builds on it for example PCP is for sat
or the basis for theory of approximation
for NP hard problems
um and Saturn is sort of like key in
many many areas logic and verification
um sort of parameterize complexity
um average case complexity and so on
um and then even from the point of view
of lower bounds the sort of the
algorithmic approach to Circuit law
bonds civilians which is goes by a
satisfibility it's via designing
non-trivial algorithms for satisfy but
if a circus satisfiability so
non-trivial algorithms for csat where C
is a class of kits imply see low bounds
from something exponential times so um
so that's kind of an interesting
connection which goes where Saturn tells
us something about low bounds so on the
other hand we know much less about mcsp
still despite all the recent work on it
and um part of the project no matter
complexity of this semester and all the
work that's happened so far is to
understand mcsp and its relatives that
we'll be looking at soon defining and
looking at soon as well as we understand
sat trying to understand the
relationship between them better and the
complexity better
um so sat has various nice properties we
can ask if mcsp and his relatives have
such properties like search traditional
reductions and so forth
um sat is sort of like extremely uh kind
of relevant to other areas
um both in theory and outside and we can
ask for that's the case for mcsp and of
course we also want to understand the
relationship between mcsp and sat better
between Black Box complexity and white
box complexity better
so that's sort of like um the
overarching sort of theme
um
so um just as so there are many variants
of satisfiability for any circuit class
we can Define csat which is just
satisfiability for the class C of
circuits similarly there's variants of
MCS speakers Point all the circuit
classes as well so given any circuit
Class C we can Define the problem C and
CSP where the input is a true stable of
a Boolean function f and a parameter s
and the question now is whether F has C
Circles of size at most s
um so
um intuitively you might think that
cmcsp should be harder if C is more
powerful plus
um so uh so for example the general
Boolean circuits maybe it should be
hardest of all because it's um yeah it
seems much more difficult to know
whether a truth table has small Boolean
circuits and say whether a small dnfs
dnfs are easier to analyze
um but this isn't formally the case we
know it's a case for satisfiability that
if C is a more powerful class then
um then sat reduces to csat um so if C
is more profit loss than C Prime C Prime
side reduced to csat but this is not the
case in general for for mcsp and
um the kind of the complexity can be
potentially be non-monotonin C so as a
power of C increases
um yeah the problem could either become
easier or harder we don't really know
which is the case so for example it's
been known for a very very long while
that dnf mcsp is NP complete so if C is
a class of dnfs then
um it's in fact
um uh NP complete whether a truth table
has small dnfs or not
um and this is using a reduction from
from set cover
um however NP computers mcsp which is
about General Boolean circuits it's
still a major open question so if the
the complexity was monotone and the
clock the power of the circuit class and
this should be harder than this and we
should automatically have
anti-completeness
um so so it's interesting in general we
understand cmcsp better the weaker C is
and this is related to the fact that we
can kind of like um
we have better understanding of circuit
low bounds for frequency
um so that's related to the
understanding of c and CSP as well so
for example we know that dnf mcsp is
then pre-complete but we also know that
we can approximate the the minimum size
of a dnf Computing a truth table
um up to like um a law capped land
factor using approximation for set cover
and we don't know any such approximation
from mcsp so while dnfmcsp is npcomplete
it's also has some approximation
algorithm where the good approximation
ratio and that's because we understand
DNS fairly well
any questions about this so this is um
so so we've seen mcsp we've seen mcspe
of s where there's a parameter and now
there are all these variants based on
circuit clause and changing the circuit
laws
um and now we're going to go into other
complexity measures Define all the
complexity measures and meta complexity
problems based on them so as we said
before circuit size can be thought of as
complexity measurements strings and mcsp
is a conditional problem corresponding
to this to this complexity measure
um and similarly we can consider other
complexity measures and the completion
problems corresponding to them
um so for example we can consider
homograph complexity and then various
resource bounded variants of tomograph
complexity
um Levin's version of K level T
um which we will Define soon KS which is
spacebound Commodore complexity polytime
bound chronological complexity and a
version of Chromebook capacity Define a
studied by Islander which um is closely
related to Circuit size
okay so um first for chronograph
complexity I mean yeah you might be
familiar with this material but yeah
just want to make sure that we're on the
same page so how do we Define cornrow
complexity we have some fixed Universal
turing machine you right so um use a
fixed Universal trading machine and
chrome compasses define respect of that
so this is quite different from circuit
complexity it's more of an absolute
measure right it's just a circuit size
it's very concrete well here everything
is done with respect to this fixed
Universal turing machine
um it's just kind of implicit so for any
string X
um in Sigma star let's let's say Sigma
zero one k of X is just a minimum size
for a program such as the universal
machine generates X on an empty input
right so the program on an empty input
generates X
um and similarly there's a sort of a
conditional variant where you start off
with an input Y and you look at the
smallest program that generates X from Y
and these conditional variants have been
started quite a bit recently as well and
so I just already introduce them here in
this context you can define a
conditional variant for any measure
on so intuitively a k of exercise the
smallest program that produces excellent
run on the empty strain and
um just some simple examples so K of 0
to the end of string of zeros which at
most log n plus order one since we can
just sort of encode n into the program
and then tell us that it's the program
tell the program there's essentially n
zeros
um order one best to describe program
that output 0 to the N given n so that's
at most log n and for certain ants it
might be much smaller
um and and more kind of interesting
example if you take the first n digits
of pi then first n Bits Of Pi the common
complexity of that is also at most sort
of log n plus order one because there's
efficient procedures to generate the
first n Bits Of Pi um given n
so um this kind of like common
complexity gives you a sense of the
complexity or the randomness of a string
so
um yeah and and most strings a structure
the strings produced by short programs
are the ones that are structured
um so there's just a couple of basic
properties of commodore complexity first
of all the every string has come out
complexity at most its length plus a
little bit because you can describe the
string just by giving a program that's
the string itself to gather the
instruction to just copy it out right so
the program has X in it and then you
tell the the program that it just needs
to copy X out into the output tape
that's the extra order one bits
um and this is uh describes uh X
precisely so um so there's a case for
every X
um and um from now on I'm going to be
ignoring the universal machine
um I mean for the purposes of this
workshop and this program mostly the
universal machine doesn't really play a
big role because
um if you especially a different
Universal machine that changes the
normal complexity but most a constant
and these constant additive terms don't
seem to make a difference in practice
um when there's some exotic kind of
results where they do but for the
purposes of this Workshop really not so
we're just assumed they fixed a
universal turing machine and work with
that
um and so we have this sort of like
upper Bound for any X that common
complexity is at most length of the
string and we also have this lower bound
and most strings are um are hard
required control normal complexity at
least n minus one for example and this
is by straightforward counting argument
um I mean for any I there's going to be
at most two to the I strings or tomorrow
complexity I since they're at most true
to the eye descriptions of length I a
description is just a program of length
I and that's of course 2 to the I of
those each one can produce at most one
string so there's at most two of the eye
strings of this kind and so there's at
most two to the N minus one strings or
complexity less than n so there's got to
be some string which has common
complexity at least 10 by the particular
principle and um if you look at for
example the threshold n minus one you
get that at least half of all strings or
more complexity at least n minus one and
such counting elements are going to
apply to any sensible measure of
complexity that you pick
um
but yeah I'm just kind of giving you the
the argument for commonweal complexity
okay so that's Commonwealth complexity
as a measure and what about the meta
complexity problem The Meta complexity
problem is again you're given the input
a string together parameter and the
question is whether the complexity is
small right whether the K of X is at
most s
um and then we also consider these sort
of like functional problems you know
where instead of having a yes no answer
instead of a different problem they have
yes no answer you also actually compute
the complexity so K is just a problem
given a string X compute the K little
sorry this should be K complex you know
klp complexity that's a typo compute the
K complexity of X and it's not too hard
to see that these two problems are sort
of introducible to each other if you
want to reduce mkp to K you can just
sort of like compute K and then check
whether the complexity is that most s or
not and output yes if it is and if you
want to reduce K to mkp then you can
just run kind of the algorithm of nkp
but every possible s from one to n and
pick the smallest one and that's going
to be a convert complexity right so
these two problems are going to be
equivalent the respect to polynomial
time reductions but
um yeah sometimes I do filter can still
one and sometimes the other which is why
I'm measuring them both and they're both
uncomputable
um
uh and and they're going to see the
proof of that soon
um as I just said they're reduced to
each other hence It's associated with us
to one of them when analyzing the
complexity
okay so um this is an argument that you
might have seen before but but let me
review it so the uncomputative why is
communal complexity uncomputable
um suppose assume for the sake of
contradiction there's a turing machine
and the computes k
um we will kind of like uh arrive at a
contradiction so we Define
um
um the following turing machine and that
accepts X if and only if the polynomial
complexity of X is at least n and by the
basic property of normal complexity we
saw in on the previous slide and accepts
at least one string for each input
length M right so um since we assume
that the turing machine ended computes K
this is sort of like a valid turing
machine and it accepts at least one
string for each input length n and now
we can define a stray sequence of
strings as follows x sub n
um where x sub n is of length n
um we Define x sub n with the let's go
graphical first string of length and
then capital N accepts we know the
Kaplan accepts at least one string of
each input length so there's got to be
so x sub n exists for each n and now
notice we can compute x sub n given n by
just simulating n capital n on strings
of length and little n and lexographical
Order and outputting the first such
string it accepts right because N is a
decider and a security machine that
always holds um and we can just sort of
run it on on the strings of length n
until we find one on which n accepts
um and so this is a this gives an
algorithm for computing x sub n
um so this implies that K of x sub
balance of most log n was order one
because given description of of n which
is just log n Bits to describe n and
this program we're able to Output k x
sub n
but by the definition of x sub n k of x
sub n is at least n right um because n
accepts only strings of high complexity
so this is a contradiction for large
enough n so so this is a kind of like
diagonization argument that's quite kind
of common uh when when considering
complexity and its variance but just
won't give you
um a taste of that a reminder of it
um and and also to I also want to
mention something that's um kind of like
um relevant to the question of proof
complexity so
um all of this is sort of like very
straightforward I mean like pretty
Elementary but but these Elementary
considerations are kind of related to
deep issues the foundations of
mathematics so to to questions such as
um or results such as girls
incompleteness theorem that no sort of
consistent accidental system can prove
all truths about the alphabetical
natural numbers we can prove like very
strong and completeness result by
arguing about complexity in a similar
way to how we showed on computability
um and so this is just sort of a variant
of the argument we had before but but
let me tell it to you so um like this
sort of indicates a deep interactivity
of stronger complexity as a measure
um and this is a theorem of shaytan so
let X be any sort of effective
asymmeters will sound proof system I'm
not going to Define that but
um it's sort of just just intuitive what
it is so consider any sort of proof
system like piano arithmetic which is
effectively accessible and so on then
there's only finitely many M far too
many integers M for which a statement of
the form that the control complexity of
X is at least 10 can be proved in X so
in a sense the truth about which strings
have high control complexities and
accessible to any standard proof system
there's only finitely many and for any
given proof system where you can prove a
statement of this form
and this proof again is by a similar
diagonization argument to how we saw
before I mean suppose for the sake of
contradiction that the infinitely many M
for which the statements provable and X
we can then
um figure out how to find such an X just
given just a description of M because
given M which can be represented by log
M bits we can computably find an X such
a k of X is at least m is provable and X
just by enumerating all possible proofs
of such statements in parallel until we
find one right we know that one exists
by assumption there are infinitely many
amps which is approval so we know that
one such statement exists and we can
just like look for proofs by a
dovetailing argument in parallel until
we find the first one but this x that we
find has now been described in log M
bits so it has come over complexity at
most log n plus order one and again for
large enough n the spontanex K of X at
least M so if you prove the statement K
of X at least M that should be true by
the soundness of the system and and this
is contradiction to um the upper
boundary complexity of X so it's a very
simple argument where it has sort of
very kind of like a powerful
consequences
and if you're feeling pessimistic then
you might think well I mean it's a
possibility that some sort of analogous
result might hold for complexity theory
that instead of complexity if you look
at say circuit size and you look at
proof systems which you work in that may
be proving circular bounds is hard for a
similar reason
um but yeah let's not be that
pessimistic for now it's just kind of
something useful to know um about in
general
okay so um having defined control
complexity I mean that's not going to be
of very much interest to us because it's
uncomputable but there are all these
kind of resource bounded variants which
will be uh will be useful to us and
interesting to us so so let's get into
them and say a bit about them so um so
these are variants where you look at
like restricting the running time of the
turing machine or somehow charge the
turing machine for the time that it runs
for right so if you use a fixed time
efficient Universal turing machine we
can look at K Little T of X which is
um the middle of the program size plus
the log of the time which is required to
generate X right so the log of the time
that required to generate X from P so
earlier we were just charging the
program for its size now we also charge
it for its time the time that it's taken
um to produce X
and um but similarly to before we can
show that for every X scale T of X the
most sides of X Plus log of size of X
this extra log term is because
um we can use a program that just
represents X and copy it out into the
output type but now that runs in linear
time so um T is linear in size of X that
creates this additional because of this
this additional term it creates a log
size of X term here
um and then but by counting arguments as
before there's a string of length and
such that calculative of X is at least n
and at least half a strength of kilogy
of X at least n minus 1.
um so note that Congo complexity is at
least at most scalar T of X because
you're charging in addition for that
time here and for more complexity just
charges with program size so this is all
this always holds and why scalar T
interesting so I mean for our purposes
it's interesting because it's uh we see
the next slide because it's a problem in
exponential time
um which is sort of complete for that
class but um it's interesting in general
because of Levin's Universal search
algorithm
um which is sort of like um this uh the
school idea where you if you're looking
for the optimal time required to solve a
search problem suppose we have a
polynomial time computable relation R
and we want to find a y for which R of Y
holds and we know that such y exists
um what's the shortest time in which we
can find such a why
um we can kind of characterize that in
terms of candle T complexity so this can
be done in time T of n times poliovan if
and only if there's a witness why with
small scale T complexity
um and this again is not too hard to
show I mean One Direction is that if you
can do it in time of tfn times poliovan
then you're effectively generating this
witness why just from the description of
Van
um in time T of n so
um essentially the cost of that will be
locked the event for the running time
and log in for the for the program size
so that's what you'll get for the klt
complexity of Y so one implication is
easy to see but for the other
implication
um essentially there's sort of like this
optional search idea which is that you
just look for Witnesses in order of klmt
complexity of increasing klt complexity
and if you do this carefully you'll see
that you can do it in time that's um
um yeah at most tfn transport your plan
so um so this kind of like um cool
relationship between kind of like the
optimal time for a certain search task
and this kind of a complexity measure
which points out why it's an interesting
measure
[Music]
I'm sorry you mean literally or
capitalism
oh
[Music]
um
say giving here and here yes because if
I put here uh
they're two different teams
I mean sorry Kennedy is just think of it
as atomic it's just a name is
X it takes it
takes us to Output so then I'll take the
size of p plus the number of steps we
could call it a different letter
yeah I think that's yeah
well I mean again this input is a string
together
next year the size of most ads
um and the search problems are the
functional problems rather given string
X compute the klb complex
um an observation is that these problems
are an exponential time because you can
just sort of like
um yeah I mean like the exhaustive
search algorithm is an exponential time
because if you want to like try all
strings of klt complexity at most n that
X exponential and end time uh just by
taking a boot for search for optimal
program so you can just try
um various programs in order and find
the the one for which P plus Lottery is
smallest and that takes exponential time
um and in this great paper which kind of
has been very influential area I mean
every calendar and others showed that
mkltp and klp are hard for exponential
time under various kinds of reductions
under normal polynomial size
non-adaptive reductions so that's not
very important exactly what these
reductions are but under some reasonable
notion reductions and non-trust polytime
Turing reductions so so in fact um for K
Little T we know that it's actually hard
for X so it's NX when it's it's hard for
X so it's complete for X under such
reductions so this is a case where the
medical complexity problem is sort of
like representative of the of the
complexity class and we dream that
something similar might be possible for
NP and for
um time-bounded versions that are in NP
um note that this this kind of hardness
result is still insufficient to
establish that this problem is not in
polynomial time because
um from MK little TP to being in
polynomial time you just get that X
percent poly size or X because NP both
of which are possible we haven't ruled
them out yet so um we still don't know
how to show that mklotp is not in p and
that's sort of a major open question
about kill t
IES
oh sorry
um no no he doesn't
um yeah and then um there's sort of like
K uh capital S which is sort of like a
space a bounded version so
um very similar to klt except that now
you can store the minimum program plus
space bounds such that you produce a
string and space at most s
um and we have a similar bound upper and
lower bounds for uh K capital S and K of
X is at most KL sub X um so just as with
as with uh as with kldt and
um so yeah sorry this should be a
polynomial space here so um just a scale
t m k l t p and klt are an exponential
time these problems are in polynomial
Space by doing a Brute Force search and
um analogously to klt these problems are
known to be hard for polynomial space
um under similar kinds of reductions in
fact you can get a better uh hardness
result versus probability time during
reductions here but again we don't know
that mksp is not in log space so that's
an open question about the spaceman
version
um and then this fundamental time
boundary complexity where you just sort
of like so this isn't a fixed problem
but it's a family of problems so if you
fix a polynomial time bound T and you
kind of like um uh so sorry so there
shouldn't be a log T here here you're
just counting the program slices the
minimum program size such that U of P
comma Epsilon equals X and at most T of
size of X steps that there isn't this
additional log T term that that's that's
a mistake
um so that's a way of kind of like
um restricting complexity to uh fast
programs programs that run in time
um polynomial in the size of X
um and again that's kind of some easy
upper and low bounds and kind of
relationship with complexity
um and again we can Define these sort of
like meta complexity problems
um
and in this case they're an MP because
we can kind of like guess a program and
check in polynomial plan that the
program outputs
um the string a program size at most s
and and check the program outputs the
the string we have is input
um and yeah and and then you get also a
way to compute the complexity exactly in
polytime than MP Oracle
and it's open with the nuc forms NP hard
so that's a big open question how are
all of them are harder one-way functions
exist
um this has been known for a long time
due to the National proofs paper and the
work of cabinets inside and uh
statistical zero knowledge is not
reduced to them all
um that's work Valentine does
and finally so yeah we've already seen
quite a few of these measures but
finally K capital T which is the notion
defined by Islander so here you assume
you have a turing machine which is
random access to the states which can
kind of like access any cell of its tape
um yeah and kind of like logarithmic
time and um we do this so that it makes
sense for the machine to run in
sublinear time we want to kind of like
Define what means for machines run
sublinear time and to do that we have
random access and then
um we Define this notion where we again
kind of like cost for time but now the
cost for T rather than log of T
um
except that that now you're not asking
the program to Output X fully you're
asking it output X implicitly given kind
of an index
um in X you wanted to Output that that
bit of X so given an index I in X you
want to Output the I to a bit of X and
at most D steps and if you think about
it this kind of like feels a bit similar
to Circuit size where also you you kind
of like you're outputting a fixed bit of
the truth table in size uh s right
circuit size and similarly here you're
operating a fixed bit in time at most D
um and so so again the sort of like yeah
easy to prove upper and low bonds
um and um one of the reasons why
Islander defined this notion was to find
a version of commodore complexity as it
relates to Circuit size it turns out
that K capital P and the circuit size
are like polynomial related but K
capital T has some nice features in the
sense that
um like these counting arguments mean
that the strings of of kind of maximal
capital T complexity this will K capital
T So strings of Maximum K capital T
complexity
um but we don't know the same for
circuit size we don't have have a very
kind of precise sense of what the
maximum circuit size is so we have sort
of like better sense of how K capital T
complexity is distributed than of
circuit size and that's what makes this
interesting to um to study
but I is encoded in binary here that's
right yeah yeah yeah that's right thanks
[Music]
um and again yeah we can Define The Meta
complexity problem and that's an NP um
and it's open whether it's MP Hub and
just as before it's hard one-way
functions exist and it starts because
Zero Energy reduces to them to these
problems
okay so um
understanding the complexity of
individual medical complexity problems
is challenging
um so yeah but it also seems very hard
to come up with the reductions between
them the worst case setting so um there
are all these questions that we have
about for each of these problems what
the complexity is
um and it's not so easy to find
relationships between these questions
for example it's even unclear whether
it's with mcsp if you have like
threshold Capital into the 0.5 but that
reduces stamps you feel threshold
Capital 0.1 or the other way around uh
it seems kind of quite hard to establish
such reductions and it's also hard to
establish kind of reductions between
these problems between say mcsp and K
poly or mcsp and K capital T though we
know the circuit size and capital P are
polynomial related so um the sum kind of
uh things that we know like all the
above problems pronoun time reduced to
come over complexity except maybe klp
but uh and even that's not trivial so
there's some things that we know but
essentially no reductions are known
between these resource bounded different
methodology problems I think you can
choose into them are fun to enter the
system 200.1 but the other day so you
just continue to Circle for like 10 to
0.4 times
so it might be in One Direction
yeah yeah so that might be the case so
yeah it's important but yeah certainly
it releases between various measures is
difficult and with the same measure
sometimes I think using like padding
kinds of arguments you've got maybe
um yeah yeah
um so these are all sort of like worst
case kind of like uh questions and it
turns out that with the average case
setting the things are somehow cleaner
and more robust
um and one of the nice things about
these meta complex performances is very
natural distribution namely the uniform
Distribution on instance of matter
complexity problems
um but in order to consider average case
complexion with respect to this
distribution we need to consider zero
error complexity because medical
platforms typically have far more no
instances than yes instances so um
um if you consider kind of average case
complexity where you can make errors
they can always just say no and that
would be an efficient algorithm that's
correct so it makes sense instead of
consider zero error complexity and
um this turns out to be closer later to
the National proofs of Ross Brown and
bluebridge I should point out that it's
also kind of interesting to consider
um bounded error Advocates complexity
you just need to use different
distributions and in fact that's how
Leon pass showed like this connection
with one-way functions and there's other
results which um which use bounded error
applicates complexity so both of these
kind of Notions
are interesting for for meta complexity
problems I just want to point out that
we only looked at worst case complex so
far but the average case complexity
setting is interesting too and there's
different sort of distributions and and
conversions large case complexity you
can use
um and there's also approximation
variance so um in fact there's at least
two national Notions of approximation we
can consider the first is
um where you approximate the complexity
of a string so you want to distinguish
say strings with high Little P
complexity from strings with low calcity
and the second is where you're trying to
approximate the string Itself by a low
complexity string so for example you
want to distinguish between strings
um say if you if you look at like
circuit complex you want to distinguish
two tables of functions that have small
circuit size from functions that are far
from having small circuit size meaning
that they have relative harming distance
at least say 0.2 from any function with
circuit size Capital enter 0.1 and these
are both interesting and Horizon kind of
natural ways the first comes up for
example in worst case to average case
reductions for meta complexity we'll see
that uh as the boot camp goes on the
second comes up questions and learning
theory because the learning theory when
you're learning circle you're typically
interested in learning like a circle
that approximates your function well and
that corresponds to the notion of
approximation here
I'm just kind of like going over this a
little
bit
more quickly because I'm kind of
um running out of time but um yeah so I
just want to spend a little bit of time
on these last four slides where I think
very very briefly talk about medical
practice is a tool so so far I've mostly
spoken about my record this is a topic
what are these measures what are the
problems associated with them what's the
complexity of these problems
um but I want to say a little bit about
the broader kind of relevance and um
that that will be kind of much more the
focus on my talk
um later where I'll be kind of
showcasing these open problems that in
different areas that have sort of
connections and meta complexity but for
now just to give you a high level idea
of why medical complexity is useful
um well for circuit complexity it seems
natural and acupressure will be useful
because every no instance of NCR speaker
sponsor circuit load bound namely the
function f doesn't have circuits of size
s conversely also get low balance
encodone to the problem so in a way it's
a problem that captures information
about circular bonds so it makes sense
that to be running to Circuit complexity
it has been like a long line of work
where
um essentially all known circular bonds
to explicit functions have also been
shown for mcsb
um using connections with your
Randomness so in a way
um it's interesting that um yeah I'm not
sure that all such strong low bonds and
offer SAT but for mcsp using kind of
like uh technical Randomness we can
recap capture almost all known circuit
load bounds so it's underway in mcsp is
related to Circuit complexity and also
this is a sort of like hardness
magnification phenomenon which is kind
of interesting fancy speed and other
meta complexity problems where for
certain parameter values if you show
just like slightly non-trivia lower
bounds for example to show that mcsp
will Capital land to little o1 parameter
does not have circular size and 1.01
then that gives you a very strong
complexity implication namely the MP it
doesn't equal p so this is kind of like
phenomenon which is interesting for meta
complexity there's some multiple reasons
why matter complexity is kind of
connected to Circuit complexity
um and then um that's kind of rather
learning theory as well it's I mean
learning is closely related to some of
the search versions of mcsp and other
meta complexity problems
so um here are the learning modelers so
the learner is given Oracle access to a
Target function
um and it outputs a good hypothesis if
such a hypothesis exists uh So Good Hope
artists may be one that approximates the
target function well
um and this is kind of like close to
solving the search version of mcsp
um given a truth table output a small
circuit for the truth table if one
exists right so
um so this is sort of like uh you have a
witness which is a small circuit and
what output that witness uh Witnesses at
least a good approximation to the
original truth table
and intuitively is an efficient learner
what can solve the search version
approximately just by running the
learning algorithm and kind of answering
all Oracle queries by looking at the
truth table
um and then finally you can even check
that this hypothesis is outper learner
is correct by just going over the truth
table and seeing that it's a good
hypothesis so learning implies that you
can solve the search version of mcsp
approximately and this very influential
paper of common C note particles or
cabinets and color call over showed that
in fact the converse um there's a
Converse to this as well that even an
efficient decision procedure for mcsp
even if you have an efficient algorithm
for mcsp where you have an entire truth
table that can be used to get efficient
Learners so
um yeah this is a paper that's had like
a lot of impact in this area
um and then the relevance to crypto um
just kind of one reason why America
complexity relevant to crypto if you
look at CRM generators which are
essential to encryption and other
cryptographic tasks sriim generator what
it does is it Maps short random States
longest your random strings and these
two Ram strings are indistinguishable
from random strings
and just one observation is that the
outputs of the prg all have low
complexity according to these various
measures
um that we've defined because it can be
generated from a short seed efficiently
so that implies for various measures
that have low complexity and just by
counting arguments clearly random
strings do not have low complexity
um so the security of prg relies on not
being able to distinguish low complexity
strings from high complexity ones
because purely random strings of high
complexity and the outputs of prg have
low complexity so what this shows
essentially is the pseudonymous implies
the hardness of meta complexity but in
fact the converse is true as well in
various settings and this work of Leon
pass and others sort of establishes this
so this is sort of just one reason why
medical complexity is relevant to crypto
and there are others and finally the
relevance to proof complexity
um through the natural proofs barrier
Ross Brown rudich
um so Roswell Rooter should identify
this barrier to Circular load balancing
and strong circuit classes by showing
that known explicit low bounds against
weak circuit class satisfy this property
but under standard crypto assumptions
there are no proofs against strong
circuit classes such as glass of normal
size Boolean circuits so they sort of
Drew a boundary between the low boundary
known thus far and the low balance we
want to show for circuit classes such as
formulas or general Boolean circuits
um and National proofs turn out to be
very closely related to mcsp so existing
natural process is equivalent to
efficient zero error average case
algorithms for mcsp and thus like the
interactive mcsp is sort of crucial to
the meta-mathematical barriers circular
bounds so
um in a way it's not just about mcsp
it's not just around the compression low
balance but also the barriers to
complexity low bonds
so I mean yeah this is all fairly quick
I just want to give you like a very very
kind of like rough sense of of why
there's connections to these different
areas and in the in the next talk I'll
kind of like go into several problems in
more detail and kind of give you the
background and the connection to matter
complexity just to kind of give you a
sense of concretely which kinds of
directions might be interesting uh to
look at
that's all what happens
foreign
oh it's just an observation it's in a
paper by the chuchi and but it's just an
observation
foreign
[Music]
circuits maybe Quantum circuits as well
I don't know but so I was just saying
that my next talk I will say something
about algebraic complexity and yeah and
so the directions kind of connected to
Quantum computation as well is that like
a notion of complexity there which I
mean there's been a little bit of work
on it but I think there's still a lot of
work to be done understanding that yeah
yeah it was a corporate break and we'll
resume at 11.